the times my arm acted up I thought it
was because of other stressful things
like bathing alone or being served the
wrong kind of tapioca but now I think
back on it every incident was hatchet
induced you know I probably wouldn't
even be in this predicament if there
weren't so many hatchets in this house I
think we should just get rid of them but
Albert you don't understand
I like hatchets I know you do but you
live with a man who doesn't have the
capacity to be around one safely I mean
how many people and servants have to die
before we realize that nothing's enough
wait so you're saying I should give up
my hatchets just because they cause some
people to add violence that's exactly
what I'm saying
first you did my hatchets then you take
my buzz saws what's next my timber jigs
then all my supposed to chop beaver
carcasses or defend myself in a mutiny
can use a gun a mutiny that would take
forever load darling
I'm just saying that I think this house
would be a lot safer especially my
misbehaving hand if we got rid of the
hatches or it's just some kind of
waiting period so I get my head on
straight Albert that's crazy
every man some children and me should be
armed with the hatchet I mean think
about it if you'd had a hatchet you
could have killed your attacker before
he killed you and not Teddy didn't kill
more you could have thrown your hatchet
at Frederick's hatchet and stopped it in
midair then no one would have died no
one did die either way
the point is hatchets don't kill people
people without hatchets do because they
basically kill themselves by not having
hatchet
think about it have you ever seen a dead
body with a hatchet in its hand
I want the money I want the fame I want
the whole world to know my name